yeah you're in great shape you stay in
great shape yeah yeah you're
vegan are you vegan yeah four years yeah
[ __ ] yeah love it what made you go vegan
oh i was working with
damian mander who runs the international
anti-poaching foundation
his movie his documentary comes out
today actually uh akashinga
it's uh it's on i believe nat geo okay
i'm not supposed to promote them because
i'm on discovery channels
but it's a it's a story about his team
all female run anti-poaching unit from
the rangers to the managers to everyone
it's all female
they've got laughed out by the guys in
the beginning and now
everyone gives them the respect that
they deserve it's called akashinga which
means the brave ones
and they're they're out of they're
trying to save animals where in zimbabwe
can i ask you something about the
anti-poachers because i know
they're poachers obviously just by
definition they're not following any
laws
did they have to follow any laws when
they hunt i mean hunting poachers isn't
the right term but you know what i mean
i i believe when when
damien first went out there uh the law
was i think it was
mugabe said that poachers could be shot
on so that's what i had heard
you're allowed to haunt the poacher but
he be him being a humongous
white australian guy he didn't want to
get anyone offside so
he was trying to arrest them and that's
what he continued to do so i went out
there and worked with him for a couple
of weeks shooting a documentary
embedded with the rangers like went
through unarmed combat training
they gave me a five minute lesson on how
to handle a snake and then gave me a
deadly black mamba
so like i immersed myself right into it
wait wait what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you mean
they gave you what do you mean they gave
it to you
like they put a handed black mamba on
the ground and why
me gave me uh like the scooping pole
yeah and so
i i didn't i needed my good hand to grab
the tail of the snake and my job was to
get it from the ground
catch it and put it into the tub and so
i needed this hand for catching the tail
and i need this hand for holding the the
snake pole and so i put it in my hand
but the problem is when i lift up
something heavy
the muscle can activate sometimes opens
the hand and drops it
and so i i could turn it off i can press
that button turn the hand off so it
won't open
so i did that had the pole scooped up
the snake grabbed the tail
but the weight of the pole and the snake
together were too heavy
my wrist rotated dropped the pole and
the snake to the ground
the snake started coming back up the
pole towards my face
so i can't everyone's the camera guys
have stopped filming everyone's
screaming at me to drop the snake
they don't know i can't because i've
turned the hand off and so i've got the
tail here
and i'm doing this crazy snake dance
trying to create distance between
its head its tail and my body just
bouncing all
everyone screaming at me finally got it
under control put it in the bucket and
that was it done with snakes and they
see for me
like there's something in you that
isn't in me like like like you
got attacked by a shark but now you swim
with sharks
see it's the opposite of i think what i
would do which is
if i get attacked by a shark yeah cool
lesson learned yeah the natural
black mama would be a hard pack like why
am i doing this yeah but so
do you is it just like in a is it for
you just an adrenaline thing or is it
for something where you're like i just
have never done it so i'm going to do it
i just figured i'm australian
sharks snakes dog bit my whole nose off
yeah yeah what animals love yeah when i
was a kid i gave a
strange dog a hug because we weren't
allowed to have pets in my house my
parents had four crazy kids so no dogs
so i'm pretending this dog is my friend
and it's my dog showing off to the other
kids to look cool
and i went to give it a hug goodbye and
i just went ah ripped my
whole nose apart god you an animals man
yeah [ __ ] well they love me
they don't mess with them yeah i'm so
tasty but but with that snake they were
just trying to
like it was teaching a lesson no i was
part of this oh just
to demonstrate what the rangers have to
go up against what they have to do when
they hunt when when they're going after
the poachers right yeah and you say they
were arresting him
the poachers though obviously armed with
weapons yeah are they
shooting at you we didn't encounter any
armed poachers when i was there but if
the poachers start shooting they
shoot to kill like they'll shoot back
jesus and are the people who are hunting
the poachers like
this dude that you're talking about he's
a trained what's his past yeah
he's he used to be a clearance diver
like me then he went to the tactical
assault group as a sniper with the
special forces
then he got out of the military and he
did two two sorry 12 tours of iraq
and so he was working as a military
contractor out there and then he was
training the local government soldiers
so poachers ain't [ __ ] to him it's not
like they're like full-on man like that
the poachers aren't
they crept into the villagers and
they've killed a bunch of his rangers in
their homes
there's a bounty out on his head these
poachers are ruthless and they're all
funded by the chinese
uh partially by the europeans as well
but it's the china it's the asian
marketplace
what is it there is it rhino horizon
yeah yeah they're hacking the faces off
of these rhinos and that's what
ultimately led
damien there he was there on a break
from iraq he was doing a safari
and they came across a rhino his whole
head hacked off and he's like my skills
can be better
used here so ham moved there over the
course of
many years he utilized his paramilitary
training and started the anti-poaching
foundation
so the chinese are funding these
poachers just because they want the
horns of the dinosaurs yeah so these
poachers will get maybe
200 bucks and we're on our horn is worth
more than gold and heroin once it gets
to its final destination
yeah they're only getting into what are
they using it for they need a manager
medicine medicine that doesn't do
anything no it's [ __ ] it's made of
keratin
same [ __ ] as that fingernail they think
it's an aphrodisiac like they think
same shark fins it doesn't do anything
wait are you saying i can get money from
my fingernails
pretty much yeah because i mean listen
times are tough you know
yeah right torn's down
how much am i getting from one good
fingernail i don't know how much heroin
is but it's worth more than that i gotta
tell you because my toenails are
thick but these are these poachers well
trained
oh they're not well trained but they are
native bushmen okay so they
know
if you're only getting paid 200 for
something that is worth
way more than that that means you need
that two hundred dollars yeah yeah
that's called subsistence right yeah
right right and that 200
goes a very long way in when you're
living in africa in the wild
that it's such an interesting thing
because and obviously anti-poaching but
i bet you if you ask the poachers
they'll be like we're feeding our
families
yeah yeah 100 i know that's such a
dichotomy i know situation
you know right yeah but at the same time
we've got they've got to protect this is
their vital resources
their heritage like look at them as
their family and so
they that's why they're willing to risk
their lives to go out there and how big
area because i'm assuming if you're
anti-poacher but that's a
huge area millions of square miles so
how do you narrow it down on where these
people are and where they're hunting
like how
do you like fall into that are you
following the animals drones
the good damian said the great thing
about the women is that
um they're fighting not just for the
animals they're fighting for their homes
their families
whereas the guys would get called in
from all different areas of
africa they'd spend their their payment
on booze and hookers
whereas the women are reinvesting into
their families reinvesting into the
villages
they're incorruptable apparently one of
his main guys that i worked with ended
up
getting corrupted the women incorrupted
defined corruption yeah
um basically selling off information to
poachers and poaching leaking
information leaking information yeah
and the good thing about women is they
love to gossip so they are
incredible at intelligence gathering oh
they're interesting yeah
but this this woman this documentary my
wife is going to think she's intelligent
right
but these women you can use that bet
yeah yeah these these women this
documentary they're not
fighting the poachers oh yeah look at
that picture man
she's strapped with a m16 i'm not even
trying to be mean i thought those were
men
no they're they're women that is crazy
that's an m16
yeah so and so how long has he been over
there
oh man um it's got to be nearly 20 years
yeah he built it from the ground up he
came back to australia sold
a bunch of his investment properties
that he bought with his uh deployment
money
and started this moved out there and
went in wholehearted
he's an incredible guy and so anyway the
reason i went vegan was because i was
out there working with him oh yeah you
went vegan yeah
and what was it about being out there
that made you
like why was it just you like these are
amazing animals like because i know a
lot of people
they'll see documentaries on how animals
are treated in like
like chickens yeah yeah yeah what was it
about being out there with those
massive animals damien being a massive
hero
in the military world back in australia
uh i have a lot of respect for him and
i saw him eating one night he had a
separate pot
and i'm thinking oh this this
[ __ ] he's saving the good meat
for himself
and the range is the [ __ ] so i hit him
up he's like oh i don't eat meat the the
rangers eat meat i'm like
what do you mean you don't need meat
he's like well i'm vegan like
what's that and he's like i don't eat it
i'm like why
he said well i was going out to work
every single day to try and protect
these animals and then i was coming home
and i was eating a dead animal and i
felt like a hypocrite and that kind of
struck a chord with me because in the
military
your leaders if they're poor leaders
they're hypocrites they uh
they live by the doers i say not as i do
and that's not a good leader and i want
to
perpetrate being a good leader in
everything i do and so i hate hypocrites
and so i went home and i thought you
know what i'm gonna do this i'm gonna go
vegan
and i lasted three days i've been there
better me i lasted eight hours eight
hours in between meals bro i know
i was like what the [ __ ] do i have a
headache even count as vegan
carbs yeah
you're
it's just all carbs but they're healthy
carbs yeah
dude i eat so much i love because i love
eating and i can eat as much as i want
anything i want
to know i'm vegan yeah has your body
changed you seem to actually be in
better shape
now than you were i kind of and because
i don't get any injuries
i don't they reckon there's inflammation
attached to
dairy products and eggs and all that
sort of stuff i don't know i'm not a
scientist
all i know is i haven't had an injury in
four years like no
tendinitis no like nothing i'll tell you
for me
um and i'm i'm like ninety percent
all planned i have meat every now and
then just because honestly
when i'm on the road or when i'm out
with old friends yeah
and i don't want to do the whole
explanation i'm like i'll have a piece
of whatever tonight maybe a piece of
fish
but when i am clean clean clean my and
i'm old man
my aches and pains daily aches and pains
are gone because it is
inflammation for me it's all about what
it does
my bot my stomach isn't bloated yeah
there's no inflammation in mine that
makes sense it's just a beast to do it's
harder
the disciplines it's really not once you
get used to it i don't even think about
it anymore
and i've been there with the traveling
and stuff it's you know going through
three
multiple airports in one day and yeah
like texas and arizona you're like there
is nothing to eat here yeah
so i packed some bars and stuff like
that now i've had to go hungry but
you know some people think that that
would make you want to change so you can
eat
but actually what it does for me is it
it makes me more driven
to not give in to stick to it yeah you
tell me when you were in texas and at a
barbecue place you you weren't like
you don't have any jackfruit barbecue
actually you'd be surprised mate
a lot of them do yeah yeah but sometimes
uh um
i just get a whole bunch of the sides i
don't really care it doesn't it's not
that important to me to have to eat meat
like i'd rather
not have the animal die and just live a
life trust me i know what it's like to
be eating it sucks
this fair point and now the listeners
are just
yeah listening yeah yeah you you have a
what would you call it by
robotic prosthetic leg six micro
processors
accelerometer due to a ball shark is
that correct yeah bull shark
in sydney harbor when i was in the navy
when i got off stage at the laugh
actually
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like you look like a rottweiler
you got a [ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song